Hi there, politiconiacs, my name is John Green.
I'm a novelist, and also a video blogger. When I was watching tonight's debate,
I was struck by the fact that it's that rare occasion in the world of political
debating where there is a clear winner.
The winner, of course, was Tom Brokaw.
Aside from being the longest surviving of the big three network news anchors--
what? what's that? Dan Rather is still alive?
Really? Is he like in a home or something? No? He's on HDNet?
Jesus, I'd rather be in a home.
Okay, fine. Aside from being the longest surviving network news anchor who works for an organization
I've heard of, I think we can all agree that Tom Brokaw's performance was fantastic.
He was funny and charming and showed an excellent grasp of the issues.
By the way, I apologize if this is poor quality vlogging
I played a drinking game during the debate where I had a drink every time someone said fundamental difference or my friends,
so of course I'm shellacked.
The second winner of the debate behind Tom Brokaw has to be Barack Obama.
He sounded smart, he sounded ready to go, he sounded fired up.
And while he was sounding that way, John McCain was busy walking around he background of the stage like he was lost.
This debate was all about the economy,
and I agree with the plurality of undecided voters in saying that Obama just knows how to handle that subject with a little more clarity than McCain.
Regardless of whether you think Obama won the debate, or you're for some reason crazy?
I want to say thanks for watching and participating in our political process,
and I'll see you some other time in this campfire-lighting.